chương tối qua. Quý bán nhân dân thành phố An Nội, vừa bán hành kế hoạch chương đối
tán bộ xe tắc xí trạy sang rau sang xe điện, trạy nặng lượng xanh.
Chức năm 2020 và theo kế hoạch thì ở năm nay, việc chương đối sẽ đặt là
sống mới ba đến 6.000 tư phần chăm.
Phần năm 2020, là đặt 6.000 tạm đến 20.000 tạm đến 20.000.
Còn năm 2020, đặt 20.000 tư đến 20.000 tạm.
Nó mạnh nghiệm không chăm ai chính là tảm đảm đến chiến miếng sấu vấn chăm.
Nó mạnh nghiệm không chăm ai mời thi sẽ đặt 1 chăm.
Bà kế hoạch này gắn với đề an gồm phát thải thấp.
Thành phố sẽ tưởng bước hạm trế, đến tới dừng nếu thông phân tiện sự giúp như liệu hóa thải không đặt tròn trong khu vực ám giống.
Bì bán nhân dân thành phố sẽ trình hồi đồng nhân dân bán hành hịt quên hỗ trợ trên lội phân tiện
sự giúp năng lượng sạch.
Và các chính xác chính cạnh cạnh gồm hỗ trợ lại sớt vài cho sân nghiệp trình nội tắc xin nghiệp.
Tạo nếu kiện tiếp cận vốn đại từ quy đầu từ phát triển thành phố
và khi bảo vệ mùi trường, giảm lệ phí, đăng kính, cấp bình số,
và hỗ trợ vốn như giải phòng mất mặc cho đề việc đầu từ trạm xa.
Thành phố cũng kiến nghệ kéo dài chính xác miếng một trong những trăm lệ phí trước bà lối với ô tôn liệu nhất là xa chính trình tắc xí.